Good morning questions or problems.
So today,
this week we begin to talk
more seriously about religion.
And I remind you, we're talking
about Christianity in particular.
Uh, not because of, uh,
it's spiritual teachings.
Exactly.
But we're interested in the church as a
power and as a power dealing with allied
to,
but different from the Roman empire.
Everything changes with the
conversion of Constantine.
The church becomes first
tolerated than official.
And then finally,
the sole legal religion,
except for Judaism,
by order of the emperor
Theodosius the great in three 93.
On the other hand,
in order to understand the church as a
power or the politics of this period,
we do have to understand the doctrine
because people fought over doctrine.
And as you've seen in the Jones reading,
they invoked the emperor's intervention.
This is not a question as might be what
you would expect today of a religion
split about various problems of Dogma
solving those problems itself or splitting
off into two factions.
The questions over the
relationship between the
persons of the Trinity Arianism
or the nature of priestly office.
Donatism provoked right from the
year of Constantine's conversion,
three 12 diversive fights.
And they're only the first.
I urge you to have fun with heresies.
Heresies are neat.
Professor Carlos Air is
teaching a freshman seminar.
I believe it's not called Basic Harris.
What is it?
Essential heresies. Yes. Even better. Um,
and I don't know of any quiz shows where
you can demonstrate expertise on this,
but there ought to be,
or there ought to be sites on
the Internet where you know,
you can get a perfect score.
We're only touching the surface,
the proverbial tip of the
iceberg to use a cliche.
Um, there are lots of heresies, there's
a lot of division in the church. Um,
why not just say,
hey,
you believe that the father is superior
to the sun and I believe that they're
coequal. So what? Um,
that's so 2011, uh, or actually,
so 2000,
because we ought to be used to religious
doctrines having military or other
kinds of violent effects.
So I'm not going to have to justify for
you the fact that we're spending some
time on religion, I hope. But
if you do want me to just,
just remind me what the rationale is.
If your roommates are bothering you
because you're quizzing them about the
relation between the
persons of the Trinity, uh,
have them email me or set up an
appointment and I'll explain why,
why it's important. I, I'd be glad to
do this as a, as a public service, uh,
or you know, my Facebook page, whatever.
This is a situation created by Constantine
and we've seen Constantine's have
fairly long reign, uh,
transform the Roman Empire.
We emphasize the creation of the city of
Constantinople as a second capitol and
the favor shown towards the church so
that when Constantine died in three 37,
40%, 50%, a large
percentage of the empire,
its population was Christian
when he died,
the Roman empire seemed to have
been restored to its former glory.
That chapter that begins the reading
for today in Brown's world of late
antiquity is entitled a world restored.
And he emphasizes this because
traditionally historians
saw the fourth century
through the lens of the sack of Rome in
for 10 as a period of decline in for 10
as we will discuss next week,
the city of Rome was pillaged and
partly burned by the Visigoths a,
I hate to use the word tribe,
but don't tell anybody.
A tribe of barbarians who had entered
the empire across the Danube in the
Balkans.
This was a cataclysmic event
and it ushered in successive
crises in the western empire,
the western empire that
would lead to its collapse.
This weakness of the western
empire is partly military,
partly political and partly internal,
a result of weaknesses of
instability culture and the economy.
It's always hard to say why empires
fall in some absolute sense,
even though we can see in retrospect
the signs of their decline.
One of the signs brown talks about in
the reading for today fairly extensively,
and that is the inequality
among the rich and poor grows.
On the other hand,
this is a period of inequality,
but also social mobility.
There are a lot of paths
open to barbarians.
Even in this period.
Barbarians become important figures in
the Roman army and indeed the army is a
path of social upward social mobility,
a very important one.
Okay.
In general,
as I've said,
between three 37 and four 10 between
the death of Constantine and the sack of
Rome, people did not see themselves
as living in a period of decline.
They did see themselves as living
in a period of real change,
the most dramatic of which was
the movement towards Christianity.
And the most dramatic example of that
movement is the reign of the emperor.
Julian, I've given you a
handout that shows the emperors,
um,
of this period.
Notice that some of them rain in the east,
some in the west,
and then some usually
briefly reunify the empire.
We're in a transitional period ushered
in by Diocletian when the empire is
sometimes divided and sometimes not with
the death of Theodosius in three 95.
The second, third to last of
those emperors on the list.
He had been sole emperor for three years
with his death and the division of the
empire between his son Oh
Noria ruling from Ravana,
the western capital now in what's now
northern Italy and Arcadia's ruling from
Constantinople.
From that point on,
we can really speak of two different
emperors and almost always there were two
emperors until the collapse of the
western empire in the late fifth century.
Okay.
Questions this point? Okay. So,
um,
the reign of Julian the apostate
apostate because he was born
as a Christian and tried
to restore the traditional
Roman religion, three 62, three 63.
His failure shows the weakness of what
we can call paganism or tradition Roman
traditional Roman religion.
By this time,
Christianity was too big to rollback.
Julian tried,
he tried to reestablish the temples.
He tried to reestablish the
vigor of the cults of the Gods.
He was an worshiper of
many different gods,
but he also was a philosopher.
He is a wonderful,
if sad example of an
intellectual in power.
Very few of these emperors were,
um,
what would be called intellectual
in the sense, I mean,
many of them were cultivated,
you know,
they liked the equivalent of
classical music and art. But,
um,
Marcus,
so realias is a philosopher and Julian
at least as a would be philosopher.
He had a beard. He studied in Athens. Um,
he was very unsuccessful though
people did not follow his doctrines.
He was a very good military leader.
His troops,
when he was on the Orion frontier
in what's now France and Germany,
uh, were extremely loyal
to him. But as emperor, uh,
not only did the church oppose him,
but, uh, many of his own followers did.
He died in an unsuccessful
campaign against the Persians, uh,
perhaps murdered, uh,
unclear, but with his defeat,
uh, the, um,
the end of civic polytheism
of that traditional urban
upper class worship of the
Olympian gods was in permanent.
It clips
the decree of the Emperor Theodosius
that I referred to already have three 93
proclaiming Christianity.
The only legal religion except for a
small space allowed for Judaism did not
really mean that everybody in the
empire was a practicing Christian.
The two groups that would be outside of
that definition are the people of the
country side,
the very large number of people who
would either continue their traditional
polytheistic,
local wardship of local gods or
assimilate that worship to Christianity.
We're going to be talking a lot about
saints in a couple of weeks on some
obvious level, which I don't
want to exaggerate, but
which is nevertheless there.
The saints, and there are many
of them. They are holy figures.
They're not gods, but they're
more powerful than human beings.
That saints are a kind of substitute
for polytheism and we'll talk about why
that and how that works.
The other class that tended to resist
Christianity to the last was the very
upper stratum of the
Roman senatorial elite.
The people who were the most cultivated
adherence of the traditional religion
and philosophers, people who
followed Plato, for example,
known as the Platonists,
and we're going to come to them because
they're very important for Augustine's
confessions.
Constantine was succeeded by his
sons after the two of the sons died.
Constantness ruled alone.
Uh,
constantness assured that he would rule
alone by massacring most of his family.
Julian was one of only two,
but he allowed to survive and he shouldn't
have because Julian overthrew him. Um,
you know, this is, um, this
is brass knuckle politics.
I guess the chief preoccupations of these
rulers of the fourth century were the
same as we when we started out the
Persian threat on the eastern frontier,
the barbarian threat on the Rhine,
Deb,
Danube frontier.
But there are also other problems that
the third century emperor had not faced.
And knees are religious problems.
Uh,
they are in particular
Arianism and donatism.
And we've seen a little bit about these
from the reading about Constantine,
uh, for the first assignment.
But let's go over this.
Arianism please remember that with a,
why this has it takes on a
completely different meaning. Okay.
Arian is this discredited racial
theory identified but not invented by,
uh,
Nazi-ism Arion with an I
is a follower of areas.
Areas was a priest from Alexandria
influenced by ideas from Plato about the
absolute and unknowable nature of God.
Any religion, but Christianity
in particular has a problem.
If you make God to absolute
and unapproachable than
why does he care about us?
If you make him too approachable,
then how is he powerful
enough to transcend the world?
Platonism
that is the philosophy of followers of
Plato emphasizes the absolute emphasizes
the inferiority of what we
can understand with our eyes,
with our other senses,
and the superiority of the spiritual.
The reason the spiritual is superior
to the material in Platonism and in
Buddhism and in many other philosophies
is that the material is more mortal,
rots, dies, passes away.
The problem for many people,
not just people in the modern world,
is that the material is right here
and the spiritual is kind of hard to
apprehend or prove.
But most people who think about it most
of the time in history of great that the
spiritual is superior
because it is in mortal.
Therefore,
those who emphasize the spiritual
emphasize this kind of unknowability,
the uh,
mystery,
the not easy to apprehend
ness of the super natural
for Platonists and for Ariens.
God was placed infinitely high above us.
Now,
Christianity has as its great
strength in many respects.
Just speaking of kind
of the power of ideas,
the fact that God becomes
man Christ is incarnated,
that means he becomes flesh.
This is not a common religious idea.
Mohammed is not gone.
He is a messenger.
In Judaism,
there are profits,
but they are not made of
the same substance as God.
There are religions in which a holy
man becomes kind of supernatural,
a lot of religions of the east,
but in Christianity,
Christ is God.
God is manifested in three forms.
The Trinity,
the father, the son, and the Holy Ghost.
Arianism says that Christ is essentially
different from God the father in some
fundamental way that Christ was created
by God as a way of interacting with the
world.
If you have studied Plato or were in ds
and remember some of those key concepts
in Platonism, there's the one
and then there's the demiurge.
The demiurge is this hard
working guy or hardworking force,
whatever you want to call
it, who interacts between
the divine and the material.
He's divine. All right, but he creates
things. He's the one who is out there.
Uh,
I'm creating the spirit as well as matter
creating the world and the universe.
Indeed, as we know it
well, the one is at rest.
So similarly in Arianism,
Christ is the one who's
intervening on earth,
indeed sacrificing himself
for humanity. Um, God,
the father remains in heaven.
This is not what Christianity,
most of the time teachers,
Christianity or the Orthodox or Catholic
view is that Christ and God are of the
same substance.
The Aryans,
therefore,
our subordination lists they
subordinate Christ to God.
Oh, convenient way of remembering
them is their tag line.
There was a time when Christ was not
okay.
It's a kind of supernatural
metaphysical time,
but God made Christ.
This goes against the
creed enacted at Nicea,
which to this day is the standard
confession of faith of Christian
denominations. The Nicene
creed as it is known, uh,
says that all persons of
the trinity are eternal.
Coeternal God did not create Christ.
Now,
Arianism appealed to people partly
because they worried about the trinity.
The trinity could be denounced by Anti
Christians as actually three gods.
Um, how could God be both
one and three? Uh, also,
people who worried about
the physicality of Christ,
Christ becomes flesh, dies, suffers.
How can God be God if he dies and suffers?
Arianism you have to take seriously as
something that is not just troubling.
The intellectuals is not just something
for people with a lot of time and
leisure on their hands.
It's a not for philosophy majors.
It's not even for
religious studies majors.
It's not even for the Roman
equivalent of college graduates.
The barbarians and I,
I,
I deliberately avoid calling
them the German barbarians.
But the first barbarians to
convert to this religion were, um,
more or less. And as time goes
on, historians emphasize less,
but more or less Germanic tribes,
the missionaries who converted them
work Ariens in the mid fourth century,
which is the high tide of
Arianism in the Roman Empire.
When the German tribes or the barbarian
tribes entered the empire beginning in
the three,
seven days area,
aneurysm was all but
over within the empire,
the Council of Nicea in
the three twenties. And,
uh,
the council of Constantinople in 381,
pretty much a defined
area aneurysm as a heresy.
And by three 81,
it was on the run in the empire.
But ironically,
the new rulers of the West would be
mostly Ariens well into the fifth and in
some cases,
sixth centuries.
Donatism or what the donotist,
the Donna tests here,
we're not dealing with doctrine
or metaphysical questions
of the relationship of
the persons of the trinity.
We're dealing with
the nature of the priesthood,
hence the nature of the church.
Uh,
it's a question of the office or the man.
If it turns out that I do not have a phd
from University of California Berkeley
or indeed that I am an imposter,
that uh,
somehow I tricked the Yale computer,
haven't been showing up here teaching
history to 10 and I'm just some random
guy,
you know,
like the guy who is obsessed with the
New York City transit and has gotten
various passes to get into, uh, you know,
drive trains and uh, um, maintenance
yards and stuff like that.
If I turn out to be like that, you will
nevertheless get credit for this course,
I assure you.
Um,
because Yale as a official body is the
one who grants your degree gives you
credits and they were
responsible for hiring me.
So if I've imposed a fraud on,
then you nevertheless received credit.
You don't have to do a background
search of me. You don't have to,
you know,
find out about how many pets I have or my,
my credit status or my mortgage
because you rely on Yale to do that.
Think of this then,
in terms of the priesthood,
if it turns out that the priest is
not a nice guy and alas that happens,
or a sinner
or what the donotist really cared about
was he had buckled under threat of
torture or the reality of tortured during
the persecutions of Diocletian and had
say a burn the scripture
or renounced Christianity.
If you're a priest is bad.
Is your baby baptized?
That's what donatism is about.
And donatism answers, no, no.
It depends on the virtue of the officiant.
You can't have a priest who was what they
called a Prady tour trolley tours and
interesting Latin word,
Tra d I t.
O r because it means both tradition or
it is the root of the word tradition,
but also of traitor.
It's the handing down or
handing over of something,
the giving up of something. So one
can speak of the handing down of, uh,
our family has cranberry sauce with
slivered almonds. That's our tradition.
Or handing over state secrets,
military strategy or the
scripture to the authorities.
But Donna tits accused priests who
had more, they believed had, uh,
capitulated to Roman persecute Toral
pressure in the last years of Diocletian,
they branded them as traders and they
said that they could not form legitimate
sacraments. Therefore, you in North
Africa where the donotist were strong,
you as an ordinary Christian had better
do a background check on your priest
because your marriage is a legitimate,
your baby is going to hell. Uh,
your,
uh,
whole participation in the church is as
it were short circuited by this defect.
Worse than that,
supposing your priest is just fine.
In fact,
supposing it's three 30,
Aad and your priest wasn't even
born during the reign of Diocletian,
but the guy who consecrated him,
the Bishop who anointed him was a trolley
tour or maybe that bishop was not,
but he was anointed. It's like
Christmas tree lights. Um,
at least the Christmas tree lights that
I have, the kind of analog ones, uh,
you know, their little bulbs and
if one of them goes, the whole,
um,
string goes.
If one is defective,
the proverbial bad apple
rotting out the entire barrel.
But the problem with that is that you
can't organize a church on that basis.
You can't organize a body spread from
one corner of the world to another unless
you believe that the church will
guarantee the sanctity of the individual
minister,
the office.
The fact that the guy is a priest has to
be more important than the man or else
you can only have local communities.
You can only trust if you're a donotist,
somebody you grew up with and a community
stable enough for your confident of
the ancestry.
Donatism lends itself to
what we call sectarianism.
A sect is a small,
tightly a cohesive group.
It does not lend itself to a
church that is universal, big,
massive.
And it also doubts that the church itself
has the power to overcome the defects
of its members.
Uh,
now mannequins are not exactly a heresy,
but they appear in the confessions
and they're very important.
So since we're doing a doctrinal ideas,
mannequin ism is a teaching about good
and evil that can be applied to other
religions.
Besides Christianity.
Mannequin in basically says that
good and evil have a real existence.
There is a war in the universe
between a good God and an evil one,
and this may be applied
outside of Christianity.
We're within Christianity and quit
within Christianity, but evil.
God is the devil or according to the
mannequins of this period that Augustine
for a while joined,
okay.
The God of the Old Testament.
Jehovah is the evil God and
the God of the New Testament.
The Christian God is the good one to Hova.
Jehovah is the one who
smiles a lot of people.
Jehovah is the Creator God because the
mannequins believed that matter is evil
and is the source of evil.
Spirit is good.
The Christian God created spirit.
Human beings are imprisoned in the body
and they have to figure out a way to
liberate themselves from
the Dominion of the,
uh,
evil God.
Vegetarianism for a start,
avoiding flush.
MMM.
But Salvation means casting off the flush.
Okay.
How is this different from Christianity?
I'm,
doesn't this sound to
you like regular old,
okay.
Christianity.
Mistrust of the flesh,
okay.
The devil is identified with
sexual desire or physicality.
Generally, mannequin ism is very
useful as an explanation of evil.
You know, this may not be something
that keeps you up at night,
but it will at some point a
intermittently where does evil come from?
Why is there so much evil in the world?
Why if God is good,
is there evil in the world?
Sure. Some of that may just be
to test you. You know, uh, uh,
you lose your job or your business fails,
but you'll get a better one.
But that's not the same
as horrible infant birth,
uh,
disabilities or the death of people by
starvation in the thousands or any of the
payment, you know, choose your
evil thing. Why does this happen?
One explanation is that God didn't
cause it. There's another guy.
What's the problem with
that? I mean, why, why,
why is mannequin is I'm not a bigger,
I mean in a way it is, but you know,
you will travel far to meet anyone
who says they're a mannequin.
Yeah. First of all, then God's not
all powerful. There's the years. Uh,
and so then how is he gone?
And then instinctively, I mean, what's
another problem may be with him?
I could say so what? God is limited,
you know, he's, he's trying.
Okay.
Anybody else have a sense of the moral
problem of saying the devil made me do it
takes
away response, individual responsibility.
I didn't keep those investors.
The devil cheated them.
Alright, I didn't, uh, um,
mug that uh, uh, as style
student, the devil did.
Um, anyway, this is a debate
not asking you to take sides,
but notice in the confessions,
uh,
the attitude of Augustine towards
his Manichaean experience. So,
uh,
the fourth century is a time of ideas
circulating around as Christianity starts
to define itself.
This would merely be a chapter
of the history of ideas where it,
not that the Roman emperors had to
intervene to settle many of these issues.
So just forgive me if
I'm beating a dead horse,
but heresy is important because of its
impact in shaping the church through
controversy and because it fell to the
emperor to try to resolve heresy and bus
marks the beginning of a merger of church
and state in a way that will become
characteristic of the entire middle ages.
The other thing to remark is that the
emperor did not have a lot of success with
this almost ever.
It's very frustrating for an emperor
who can get someone killed immediately.
All he's gotta do is say,
um,
you dropped that larks tongue pie,
uh,
take them away and kill him.
But he can't seem to do this with
heretics partly cause hair. It takes love,
persecution. It just
tough in this thing. Um,
so you have,
um,
the prefect of Africa writing to Jones
and saying that this bishop in North
Africa,
Kalien has been attacked as a trodded
tor and Constantine does what emperors
usually do. They appoint local
judges as experts. They say,
go and have a hearing and find out what's
going on and make a recommendation to
me,
oh,
he makes a recommendation telling the
donnas just to go home and shut up.
They don't, they appeal to
the emperor. The emperor says,
go home and shut up.
And they don't,
they define the emperor himself.
They go back to North Africa and they
continue preaching against traitors.
Constantine.
Why does he intervene?
Why didn't he just say the hell with you?
Pretty literally,
or it's a matter of opinion or this
doesn't get at the core of the faith.
Yeah.
He's afraid of upsetting God.
Remember we said that Constantine
was not much of a philosopher,
not much of a contemplative.
He had won a battle with the favor of
the Christian God. Now the Christian God,
he was the companion of the Christian God.
The Christian God has him by the hand.
If the church starts dissolving
into quarreling factions,
God is going to be angry
and his favor will cease.
We have to take the rulers anxiety
about religious unity seriously.
So he changes his policy several times.
Remember we're talking about a guy who
was able to feed defeat all his military
rivals. Scentless sinneas, you know,
running through Asia minor, caught him,
executed him a man of tremendous
capabilities. Nevertheless,
dealing with these peasants
and poor towns people and just,
you know,
from his point of view,
riff Raff who were strong in north Africa.
He couldn't get them to obey him.
Sometimes he tried compromise,
then persecution,
then just saying, nobody can discuss
this and none of this worked.
Not only did this not work,
but now Arianism came to preoccupy him.
And you can see in his letters,
there's a kind of, oh, em, gee,
I didn't realize what I was
signing up for tone to it.
At first, he was anti Arion
pretty totally. He saw it
as a denial of Christianity.
If Christianity,
by its very name is that Christ is God,
then Erin Ism would seem to be, uh,
antithetical to that fundamental thing.
So after defeating, uh, listen,
he says he learned more about Arianism,
which was strong in the east.
And his first reaction was kind of maybe
your reaction or certainly the reaction
of anybody who is more interested
in, you know, power politics,
this world,
he considered it over subtle,
philosophical and ultimately trivial,
but he couldn't get rid of it.
He couldn't get rid of it.
And now instead of appointing judges,
he summoned a council of
the bishops of the empire,
what later would be called
an ecumenical council.
Ecumenical meaning worldwide,
a universal council which met
in the city of Nicea across the,
not right across the boss
for us, but more or less, um,
uh, uh, uh,
more or less in the
western part of Asia Minor.
And it met in three 25 at
this first ecumenical council.
The last Ecumenical Council, the Catholic
Church by the way, was in the 1960s.
The early 1960s, um, under, uh,
Pope John.
Okay.
At this ecumenical council was summoned
by the emperor and the emperor,
uh,
was in the room and in a
certain respects presided,
intervened, took sides. He was
very deferential to the bishops.
He is not a bishop after all.
He is not a priest.
He does not have the sacramental orders.
But nevertheless,
he was or attempted to be the boss of
this conference and it came up with a
formula,
a definition of the creed,
what every Christian must believe,
saying that God and Christ are of the
same essence but different persons,
God and Christ and the Holy
Ghost who is not really an issue.
Yet there will be a heresy
involving the holy ghost,
but not until the end of the course.
They are the same essence
but different persons. Haim,
same essence.
The Greek word is homoousios.
Christ was begun by the
father but not made by him.
That's a tough one.
He was begat and by the father,
but not in time.
There wasn't sort of like,
uh,
three minutes after creation.
The someone wants to go out
and see what that noise is
or is it coming from
outside and we're hopeless?
No, it's okay. Thank you.
Areas gave a kind of equivocal
acceptance of this arrangement,
but the bishop of Alexandria refused
to accept areas back into communion.
In other words,
the Nicene creed defined orthodoxy,
but fighting raged for about 50 years
over the relationship between Christ and
God.
The father,
Constantine kept on
changing his mind again.
The poor guy only wanted unity.
He wanted this to go away
so that God would favor him.
Uh, he died. I'm more or less an area.
He came to believe that the area
in moderate position was the best.
Uh, this is partly because of
the absolute and trends gents,
the Bishop of Alexandria,
the Archbishop of Alexandria.
Athanasius Athanasia's
would then later be a saint,
uh, uh, considered the upholder of
the Orthodox line.
So I'm a constant.
Constantine was baptized just
before he died in this era.
Usually baptism was supposed to
mean that you embraced Christianity.
Totally.
It's Augustine particularly who's
responsible for infant baptism.
Infant baptism then means baptism.
You entered the Christian community,
but for sure you're going to sin.
The understanding in the three thirties
was more as a baptized Christian.
I am no longer a center.
So if you were in an office, like constant
team where you are shedding blood,
giving judgments,
leading troops,
you would wait until your deathbed
moment before getting baptized.
So he would be baptized on his
deathbed and by an area priest. Um,
what's the danger of this?
Paranthetically Diane?
Baptize,
right?
The proverbial bus hitting you on the
street or sudden death of another sword.
And, um, we're going to talk,
I'm sure this is going to be one of the
things you will remember with pleasure,
but briefly about sin.
Why people sin.
Um, and, uh, the,
um, uh, interaction of good
and evil in human beings.
Indeed, we're going to start
very soon because it's,
it's all over the confessions.
Let me give you a little bit of
orientation towards the confessions. Uh,
uh, which we, uh, I hope you
will read as much as possible.
Why are we reading this very
personal and autobiographical work?
Um, first of all, it is, you know, it
is a classic. How many of you mask?
I've already read it.
Okay. Certain number.
Um,
it is an autobiography
which makes it very unusual.
It's an intimate or about, it's not just
highlights of my career or my resume.
He talks about anxieties, desires, doubts.
It is therefore a portrait of the
mentality of a thinking person.
In the ancient world.
We get a better idea of the life
of the then from many other,
most other,
almost any other source.
It shows the fluidity of the religious
scene and the late Roman empire.
His father is a pagan.
His mother is a Christian.
He is first a Platonist
sort of than a mannequin.
Been a Christian Platonist and
then a more fervent Christian.
So it shows some of the religious and
philosophical options of this era.
In doing so,
we do come across important and lasting
ideas of the Western tradition about
evil, sin, body and soul.
We also are looking at the impact of
Christianity on the Roman Empire and the
relationship between Christianity
and classical culture.
Yeah,
some things to keep in mind
as you're reading this,
the book is uniquely self revealing
for its time. On the other hand,
it doesn't tell us a lot of
stuff we'd like to know more.
Time is spent going over a youthful
prank involving stealing pairs from an
orchard.
Then on Augustine's concubine,
concubine, a woman that you're not
married to who some sort of like a,
a subordinate, uh, with whom you had
a sexual relation. And indeed, uh,
um, uh, he would have a child
pairs book too towards the end.
Uh, play a lot of attention to that.
Uh, the book has a lot of prayers,
quotations from scriptures very biblically
and fuse dump would be be put off by
that because the book is a confession.
Confession has two meanings in this era.
One is it's meaning. Now that way
we usually use it confession of sin,
but it's also a confession of praise.
I confess God,
meaning I acknowledge God's
power and I praise him.
Uh, finally I just want to, uh,
go over Platonists because he both admires
the Platonists fields that they saved
him from the mannequins, uh, but
ultimately comes to doubt them.
This is described fairly well in Brown,
beginning on page 73.
Um,
but let me just take a few
minutes to discuss this.
Platonism or neoplatonism.
It's the same thing.
Neoplatonism is a kind
of religious Platonism.
It differs from Plato and his dialogues
by a little bit more mystical in the
sense of focused on the one trying to
apprehend the one and less interested in,
um, the city, the state,
or the kinds of worldly
problems that Plato dealt with.
Platonism asserts the superiority of the
spirit and the inferiority of matter.
But unlike Manichaean Isam,
which basically says that matter is evil
and spirit is good for the Platonists,
everything is good,
but there are inferior good.
So matter is not evil in itself.
It's just inferior.
We're evil comes from is the preference
of the inferior to the superior,
the preference of the material
manifestation to the spiritual.
So to take the most famous example,
because we still have
this little funny vestige,
you'll notion of so called platonic love,
love of a sexual sort is
not evil in Platonism.
What is evil is assuming that that's
all there is and not referring it to a
higher spiritual nonmaterial kind of love.
Wealth is not bad,
but the preference of wealth
over spiritual things is bad.
Here again, as we spoke at
the beginning of the lecture,
it's important to emphasize
the superiority of the
spiritual over the material
because the spiritual is eternal.
Evil comes from not realizing
the superiority of the
material, of the spiritual,
excuse me, or not acting on it, acting
as if the material is all there is
in Platonism.
Evil is a kind of falling away or a
turning of your vision to evoke the cave
metaphor.
It is a misperception and it's
the result of poor education.
If you educate people to the
superiority of the spiritual,
they will throw off
their evil ways.
The reason people
misbehave kill each other,
oppress each other,
is that they don't know any better.
And if you teach them,
they'll reform.
Keep that in mind as we turn tow.
Augustine, see what he thinks about it.
He adores the Platonists
because they were intellectuals.
He admires them because rescued him from
the trap of Manichaean dualism that is
good versus evil.
Just simple forces.
Platonism is an explanation of evil,
but for all Guston it's not
a sufficient explanation.
And that will form part of the
subject matter of our next talk.
So I'll see you on Wednesday.
Oh,
and Wednesday you'll get the
paper topics for the first paper,
which is due October 10 19.